okay so ms marvel is now at an end and
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over the finale discussing the
easter eggs in it and also breaking down
what we liked and didn't like about the
season huge apologies for missing last
week's episode one of my kids had a
hospital appointment on the morning
everything's fine we're all good but it
kind of shifted the schedule a bit and
then i went to see thor on thursday so
it had a big knock-on effect still
though i did really enjoy the episode
even if i was sat there for a good part
of it like are we the baddies this told
a lot of the backstory of aisha we
discovered how she met kamala's great
grandfather who wooed her with poetry
but i'm not a rapper you also saw how
she escaped the british soldiers after
leaving the temple really great opening
i think was one of the high points in
the season unfortunately it came to a
tragic end and had aisha being murdered
by najma at the train station now judy
kamala travelling back in time she
managed to save her grandmother during
the partition which we heard about
earlier on in the season typically in
the marvel universe when you travel back
in time this alters something and it
creates a branch that then builds a
variant timeline in order to keep these
to a minimum the tva would constantly
intervene but we didn't see them pop up
in this entry this is because this is a
fixed point in time that's part of a
self-fulfilling loop in theoretical
physics this is known as the bootstrap
paradox and it basically involves the
past creating an event in the future
that then starts its creation in the
past for example let's say that one day
a time traveler discovers a book on
their doorstep that tells them how to
build the time machine they then do this
and using the machine they travel back
in time and then leave the book on their
doorstep so that their past self can
pick it up and use it to build a time
machine everything all plays out in one
big loop and this event of kamala saving
her grandmother was always supposed to
happen which is why didn't cause any
issues the idea of a partition was of
course also reflected in najme the
partition itself was a massive refugee
crisis that destroyed many homes because
the british empire completely [ __ ]
everything up borders were created
across india and this is murder in the
clandestines who had their own crisis
with crossing borders that led to a lot
of destruction now back in the present
the portal was open but it led to the
death of najma early on we were told
that he needed two bangles to properly
open everything up and this could
explain why the clandestines ended up
clanning fodder
her essence then traveled into cameron
and we also got the idea that ms marvel
had her identity secured when her mother
found her necklace showing her symbol
back in jersey we saw bryant so bruno
and cameron meeting damage control shut
up and it didn't exactly control the
damage
i thought my jokes were bad
now the episode itself is titled no
normal which was the name of the first
graphic novel featuring the character
this is what the full series is based on
and we open up in jersey which is where
that comic was set circle q has been
pretty much destroyed but in the source
material kamala actually did this when
she tried to save bruno from getting
robbed by his brother damage controller
inspecting the scene and we get agent
diva saying this is what happens when
the wrong people get powers now this is
meant to be because she's basically a
racist i think as she's done a couple of
microaggressions in the series and she
doesn't take her shoes off in the mosque
they also have a bit where she assumes
that the sheik is quoting the quran when
he's actually doing abraham lincoln she
quickly says that she means kids and she
wants to take him in alive which is when
we cut to cameron and bruno out on the
subway last week his powers manifested
when the drone arrived and he sort of
goes wild in this episode
now cameron in the comics was an inhuman
who gained bioluminescent powers after
being exposed to terrigen mist cameron
was a genius whose families were friends
with the cats and when cameron was a kid
but they moved away for several years
when they returned in his teens cameron
ended up being exposed to the mist which
basically transformed certain people
into inhumans this activated his
abilities and he transformed into a pale
blue being that was able to emit
powerful energy although he was a loving
trust for kamala he also ended up
becoming a villain and he worked with
the bad guy lineage when nachma first
showed up i thought that she would be
based on this but big l on that fan
theory see you chump
now we then get the title sequence and
over this we can hear captain space by
janubi kargosh go to the statue of
liberty which we last saw at the end of
nowhere home this was brought up by
elaina belover and hawkeye as well and
it's its classic green rather than being
the copper that it was after its
restoration it's difficult to tell
exactly when the show is set and there
have been a lot of conflicting things
from the creative team about the general
timeline we know that the show is
obviously set after end game but beyond
that it's estimated that this takes
place in 2024 one year after end game
with no way home being full in winter of
2024-2 the shield isn't there either so
i imagine it's probably around the time
of far from home but let me know below
if you know different because you guys
are the real heroes now at this point
kamala makes an announcement that she's
nightlight to her family i am weed no
i'm night light
oh my god
i had no
idea you told them already they already
know and we discovered that the gossip
got around quickly in the house because
abu always has his phone on speaker this
is similar to the reveal in the comics
in which she went to tell her mother but
she already knew she said that she
didn't actually mind her sneaking out if
it was to help people and it was a nice
mother and daughter moment now they
start asking how her powers work and
even bring up her almost dropping the
kid which happened at the end of episode
2. it's very much coming out for her and
her parents are over the moon and so
proud of her clearly they care and i
wish my parents had been like that when
i told them i broke records when
bringing out breakdowns instead they
kicked me out the house and said they
wish they'd had a sunlight emergency
awesome and at this point nakia
facetimes kamala to tell her bruno is
missing we then get the title sequence
which is back to being in english after
urdu and hind were used last week
amongst the quick flashes we can catch
the sloth baby productions video from
episode 1 with captain marvel flying in
there's also a high school sweater with
ms marvel established 2014. well
actually miss marvel appeared in 2013 in
a captain marvel comic but her own
series starred in 2014 so we'll let you
off at the zen circle q a school bus a
cast and nokia 3310 screen a damage
control car a train station sign and
this of course all reflects what's
happening in the episode lastly we get
the newer anchor to kamala's room where
we can see amongst the posters of
captain marvel that a desktop also has
carol's symbol on it carol ends up
appearing at the end of the episode in
the post-credits scene which we'll talk
about later on in the video minima comes
in with a toffee box which was the same
thing that the bangle was sent in by her
grandmother we saw these boxes littered
her home in episode 4 and inside is her
costume that's built to reflect certain
things given to her throughout the
series willie gave kamala the blue vest
kareem gave her the red scarf she got
the bangle from her grandmother and the
mask from bruno the final piece was the
necklace which miniba found with her
symbol on it these all come together to
form her costume and it's one of my
favorite ones in phase 4. she then runs
through the city hopping on platforms
similar to the mobile game that bruno
played earlier in the series she then
stops at the grove street sign oh [ __ ]
here we go again
after the train derailed bruno decides
to go to the mosque which nakia says is
a bad idea due to all the surveillance
that the place will be under due to
america being suspicious of the religion
she's right to you as damage controls
show up and everyone has their ids ready
because they've been through this kind
of thing with the government several
times before they do play some of it
tongue-in-cheek and even have a fake out
where nakia pretends to hide her
boyfriend and this buys bruno and
cameron time to escape they end up
wearing caps which we've seen throughout
the mcu are what people put on to go
incognito and this is showed up in
movies like winter soldier and ant-man
in the wasp unfortunately cameron's
powers are too much and he starts to
overcharge they head to the high school
and kamala rings kareem and he tells her
that he can get the ladder out if she
makes it to the harbor at midnight the
friendship group reunite and even zoe
comes in to help turns out she's been
filming her tick tocks in the school and
we learned earlier in the season that
she'd been posting a lot about
nightlight which helped damage control
track her down so he sort of goes on the
same mark that she did in the comics and
though she initially started off
as a bit of a douche over the series she
ended up siding with kamala they start
to plan stuff out which allows the
creative team to really flourish and i
think the design elements like this are
what have really elevated the show it
shines when they're doing stuff like
this and they foreshadow a lot of the
battle here we can see skeletons and
hoodies which are all sketched out the
hoodies are used to make everyone look
the same and it's basically a home alone
bit now the skeleton itself is given a
knife and a grey wig and this is clearly
riffing on psycho namely how norman
bates had his mother we also see damage
controls guns on the outside which two
showed up in the she-hulk trailer this
show is going to be releasing next month
and it'll be interesting to see how this
all lines up now as we saw earlier in
the series these sonic weapons can knock
people out in a non-lethal way and i'm
expecting them to show up again diva is
told to evacuate but being the chump she
is she ignores this and sends the team
in over the top of this we can hear the
song anthem by the sweatshop boys and
it's a bloody banger these actually got
mentioned earlier in the series in a
conversation with kamala and cameron and
this itself pulled directly from the
comics i love how everyone kind of uses
the powers that they have in order to
beat them and zoe being a tick-tock star
sends this out to draw people in now as
they run through the school we see a
mural that includes ruth baber ginsburg
mother teresa and also gandhi there's
also what i think is michelle obama and
mohammed rafiq tura but let me know if
i'm wrong as it's a bit difficult to
make them out just from this shot now
kamala and cameron see that their powers
can combine and bruno interrupts them
almost kissing should have done what i
would have done and snitched on cameron
because i'm king cockblock that's quite
fun chase scene buckamala is obviously
hiding from cameron that his mother's
dead and looking like that skeleton with
the wig on cameron isn't too happy that
she's gone and this makes him go full
supervillain which pits him against
kamala she does a giant hand similar to
how she does in the comics and they
slowly start to line her powers up more
with the source material one of the big
complaints throughout the series is how
they've changed these up from the comics
but by the end she's pretty accurate to
that and even says i'm biggin though
there is the hard light still being used
her body enhance or shape shift and this
scene feels like it's ripped right out
of the comics and the avengers game
cameron runs outside and after damage
controls start to fire on him kamala
jumps in and saves the day they bring
out the sonic cannons and i believe that
this is similar to the devices used in
the incredible hulk this leads to a big
fight with a one shot tank of cameron
tearing through damage control he's
going wild whereas kamala is finessed
and using her powers to stop people
being hurt eventually he goes into full
meltdown mode and kamala has to close in
on him she says that najma sent
everything she had to protect him but
yeah i don't know if najma's plan makes
all that much sense in the end anyway
the inside of this structure they form
is also like the newer which of course
ties back to the general bad thing that
was on the horizon now she gives him a
route to the harbour and i'm guessing
that he'll pop up again soon we see him
heading to the restaurant that the red
daggers operate out of and this will
likely lead to his training there are
theories that he might get recruited by
val as part of the thunderbolts but i
think he's more likely going to end up
siding with the red daggers even though
they were enemies with the clandestine
anyway kamala is blowing up on tick tock
and we even get g willow wilson dropping
one this character was named after the
author of the same name who wrote the no
normal graphic novel we also get one
that might be a reference to star wars
kid is that him i think it might be so
apologies for my voice at the moment got
covered uh i feel fine but my voice is
just knocked so yeah this is why the
video is bad it was going to be bad
anyway to be fair but this is my excuse
this time anyway she's a viral hit
everyone loves her even the kid who she
saved at the end of episode two she's a
superhero for the muslim community and
hey nice to have this moment where she
finally finds her own identity and form
of acceptance that night her father
tells her that if she saves one life she
saves the entire world this is someone
playing on the quilt from the torah
which was used at the end of schindler's
list and it was moulded into being used
on ant-maid's gravestone at the end of
nowhere home and the spider-man ps4 game
abu tells her kamala means perfect which
is the literal meaning for it but he
also brings up how kamal means marvel he
calls her their own miss marvel and they
they said it hakuta kamal is sitting on
a lamppost which is based on a comic
cover from her solo series jumped to one
week later and we see bruno wearing the
gigawatt t-shirt that he also wore in
the comics he's now driving cameron's
car and you just need to steal his girl
and you've got it mate now from here
comes one of the big ocean moments in
the episode turns out he scanned her
genetic makeup and he's discovered that
she's actually a mutant we even get the
x-men musical sting that too appeared in
the multiverse of madness like a
mutation
now in the comics kamala was an inhuman
but they've definitely changed this
appear along with her powers inhumans
were basically what marvel tried to push
instead of the x-men in the comics
because at the time they didn't own the
movie right however they've got them
back now which is why the inhumans have
kind of been put on the back foot now
whether they will explore this more
remains to be seen but i'm guessing that
this is the ushering in immunes and that
they'll be shifting a lot of the inhuman
characters over to being them instead
black both just took another
mind-blowing l and potentially they will
shift towards this this could also allow
them to introduce professor x and
potentially kamala could even end up
going to him for training i'd love it if
they revealed that mutants had existed
the entire time much like how they did
with kamala it would be great if it
turned out we just didn't know about
them and the school had been operating
unbeknownst to most of the world even
bruno scanning her didn't pick this up
the first time and kamala could be used
as a gateway to the x-men we do have san
diego comic-con coming up next week
where we're rumored to be getting more
of the plan going forward however kamala
has to star on the marvels first and we
get a big hint towards this with the
appearance of captain marvel in the
post-credits scene kamala's bangor
lights up and starts to glow and she
then swaps places with carol this to me
confirms that they are indeed the [ __ ]
bands and this has a lot of basis in the
comics the [ __ ] bands were basically
creon effects that delved in in the
negative zone or as it's known here the
newer the nougat the new negative zone
now in the comics rick jones and captain
marvel also used them as gateways to
swap places with each other for example
we'd get what we basically have here
where they swap back and forth but never
exist together in the same scene now
it's going to be interesting to see how
they interact because of this and where
kamala actually is now she's across the
cosmos somewhere whilst carol is stuck
in her number one fans room bit creepy
now i have no idea how this is triggered
but they're clearly leaning into the
comics and setting things up to match
that where the bands swap places with
other people who knows kamala might even
be with her right now on the opposite
side of this in the negative zone
instead of being across space carol
however doesn't have the other bangle
and i was kind of hoping they'd reveal
where she found the opposite one either
way we know the marvel's is coming soon
and that it's gonna star her kamala and
photon who was last seen in one division
there's been lots of warps in reality
that the three have had to deal with and
i'm guessing that this will bring them
together great way to end the episode
anyway with a lot of questions for the
future now in her room we can also catch
an iron man helmet too so hey maybe
they'll pull riri williams into this too
somehow as we know she's going to be
popping up in black panther 2 or connect
forever
now as for my thoughts on the season i
kind of have mixed feelings on it but i
don't know if it's just how i'm feeling
about phase four in general everything
feels kind of directionless and when you
look back at phase one phase two and
phase three they all felt like they were
building towards something in their own
individual phases i think phase four
could have been heading towards more
multiversal things but it doesn't really
feel that way overall i also think that
the show has been limited by marvel's
disney plus formula quite a lot they
keep sticking to six episodes and it
just makes shows suffer so much in my
opinion the first two episodes tend to
be really badly paced in a lot of these
shows and i think in the case of hawkeye
loki moon knight and this you could have
just combined elements from both put
them together in one entry and not
really missed anything the final episode
always feels like a bit of a rush and i
wish they'd paste the series out a bit
more so we're not spending ages in act 1
and trying to get to the big stuff
saying that though i did enjoy miss
marvel i think that all the cast did a
stellar job and that they really handled
the material well lots of clear love and
appreciation for the rich cultures here
and even side characters like kamala's
parents get lots of really well
developed arcs and character moments
however i do feel that the villain plot
was pretty weak overall and that they
kind of shoehorned in a lot of stuff at
the end but i didn't mind too much
because the main characters were so well
handled i really hope that going forward
that marvel looks at shows like umbrella
academy the boys and stranger things and
that they decide to start making their
shows a lot longer eight episodes would
be a sweet spot and we've seen things
like the mandalorian that work really
well because of this just that bit of
extra time would mean that the ending
isn't so tacked on and i think it would
really help these shows knock it out the
park instead of just being serviceable
now obviously the elephant in the room
is that i'm a 33 year old white guy
complaining about a tv show made for
teenagers that can relate to a lot more
of the cultural aspects than i can
that's kind of why i've tried to focus
my criticism on things about the mcu
shows that i have rather than going over
the actual story which i do think was
good the bangle plot time travel and
just kamala in general worked really
well i just wish that the entire thing
was structured better now i do think
this is one of the stronger disney plus
entries but i also think there's
problems with it because of the format
that they seem to be sticking to after
one division did nine episodes and had
much more eyes on it than most of the
other entries i have hoped that they
realized this and decided to shift gears
overall though ms marvel was a fun time
and i am excited to see kamala's return
in the marvels i'd of course love to
hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season if you pick the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want some emails to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
boys which will be linked on screen
right now such a good season lots of
cool easter eggs in it and definitely
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]